who do you think is the best president  of all time  JFK secomist  I'm not going to have a second best  because I think there's been so much  corruption  since then I think that was a coup in  our country try a little bit  who else would you say has been a great  president we've had no one's about  George Washington  that's a safe one you said I get what  you're doing now you're being political  okay give me Andrew Jackson how about in  the last Andrew Jackson challenged the  banking cartel since six of the day  since 1960 outside of Kennedy there  there's none there's not there's no  uncorrupted you vote  yeah you do vote yeah okay  um do you do you typically vote with  Democratic policies or republican  policies and it depends on who's telling  the truth lately nobody's been telling  the truth